we've been looking at fractions and not
just you know what are they by how to
work with them operations and fractions
together right so if you recall we
looked at things like this and we said
well look if you got half of something
in another half you put it together you
should get a hole right and so we
concluded well I like to really want get
today I'll fix that little we concluded
that adding fractions you need to take
care don't choose ok you don't just
simply add the ones and then add the
twos and they'd get an answer right it
doesn't work like that that's right does
they don't remember why is it that we
for example in this case why do we add
the numerators and not the denominators
does anyone remember yep fantastic so
let me paddle back a second the
numerators and denominators Shh are not
the same kind of number and that's why
we give them different names right the
denominator tells you about the size of
the fraction ok so when you're adding
these together you don't change the size
when you add them together the size of
the fracture stays the same but the
numerators they combine and they mix up
that's why you get 2 over 2 great now
what we have a look at multiplying you
have to be similarly careful as to
what's similar with how we voted on
others before and what's different ok so
for instance let's have a look at if
you've all gone a little square for
yourself and divided into pieces ok I
picked a great day to have a smart board
today I'm gonna shade part of this sort
easy to do now I know it's not a perfect
diagram but assuming all of the pieces
that I've drawn are equal in size right
how much of it have I shaded yeah
yeah that's a quarter isn't it I caught
up now if I shade another one like so
I've doubled that right so i have two
quarters now i have two lots of a
quarter now I deliberately set it like
that because that's the way that we
first learned about multiplication right
we'd say you know two times three is two
lots of three things and that's why you
get six okay but over here we have two
lots of one quarter that's what you just
told me right and how much have I got
shaded well I could take two ways
couldn't know I could take about two
quarters shaded or any quiver lat
fraction is I can say that's a half
because you guys recognize the two
quarters and a half are the same now
rather than taking these sort of two
steps right this is up multiply across
you get two quarters as you can see
right we can actually go straight to a
half the way you do it is that what we
call cancelling
okay so what we're looking for here is a
look is too and this for okay we said
before with addition these numerators
and denominators they don't mix okay but
as you can see here with multiplication
they clearly do interact with each other
right and the way they do is what we
call cancelling so for instance you got
your two there and you fall there okay
getting out another card I consider in
this case right there's a common factor
between two and four namely to I chose
very small numbers didn't I okay so i
can say divide this by 2 which gives me
1 and i can divide this by 2 which gives
me too so looking carefully at what I've
cancelled and what's left behind right
this is the same as 1 times a half which
of course is a half right other reason
why this is a better way to approach
things is because rather going this way
this way which that makes up as bigger
and then we have to simplify them this
approach makes them smaller we like
small numbers they're easier to keep in
our heads okay